so imagine being able to create seven
videos all in one sitting so now that if
you were gonna upload one a week you
would be seven weeks ahead on your
YouTube calendar this is the type of
thinking that will get your time back so
that you have more sanity more time with
your family more time working on your
next project
imagine being able to create multiple
YouTube videos in one day with less
stress saving time and getting more
sanity back in your life I'm excited for
this episode of the think media podcast
because if you're like me you're
juggling a lot right now you've got
responsibilities maybe family maybe kids
maybe it's school or your nine to five
job or the responsibilities in your
business and so I've learned that it's
so important that we have the right
tools strategies and Frameworks so that
we can actually get more content done in
less time so that we can tap into the
benefits of YouTube which is increased
influence more Revenue More Money More
impact and today's episode is brought to
you by stream with think.com but more on
that later let's jump into it so this is
part one of our YouTube productivity
series here at the think media podcast
in this first episode we're going to be
talking about how to create more
original content in less time make sure
you're subscribed because in part two
we're going to be talking about how to
repurpose your content and then in part
three we're going to be talking about
some of the best AI tools for saving
time and getting more done but in this
first part we're talking about creating
more original content and less time and
I've got two big ideas for you today and
the first one is batch producing your
videos now you may be new to this
concept but if you've been hanging out
with us for any length of time or
creating content for any length of time
then you understand the power of batch
producing videos but I want to give you
some new tips and even just
encouragement to get back to the Grind
back to work and to schedule your next
batch shoot and so let's get on the same
page as far as what is batch producing
videos well this is ultimately how I was
able to grow my YouTube channel while I
had a full-time job essentially what
we're doing is we're saving time by
clustering tasks like the setting up of
your camera the setting up of lighting
the preparation of your video topics the
videos you want to shoot even just the
preparation of your mindset wardrobe and
anything like that and you're clustering
it all together I actually asked on
Twitter for some of the entrepreneurs
and creators following me if they batch
produce content and this is what Sherry
the biz starter said yes I do it to save
setup time makeup Etc and when I batch
create my videos I do five to seven in
one sitting so imagine being able to
create seven videos all in one sitting
so now that if you were going to upload
one a week you would be seven weeks
ahead on your YouTube calendar so how do
you do this step one plan your videos
beforehand I've learned that it's very
difficult to plan your videos and shoot
your videos in the same day it's almost
like two different sides of the brain
one is kind of a research writing
analytical side and then the other side
is the kind of creative extroverted
actually needing to deliver the content
even if you're alone talking to a camera
in your bedroom or home office and so I
actually am doing a batch of content
right now and I planned out today's
videos on a Google doc over the last
week or so maybe in a four hour block of
time and then another one hour to polish
eight different videos so I can sit down
today and record them all in a row and
when you're planning your videos you
want to make sure you define your title
I actually like to know what my title is
ahead of time my title for this is work
smarter not harder how to create
multiple YouTube videos in one day so
going into the video I know what the
title is what is the topic you know the
title and the topic and even an idea of
what the thumbnail could be now when you
plan ahead you also give yourself an
advantage by selecting topics that have
the biggest opportunity of getting the
most amount of views for example we talk
about our asq strategy answer specific
questions and if you're actually
interested in topics that get the most
views on YouTube I'm me just point you
to our free class at thinktubeclass.com
I teach three Surefire video ideas
guaranteed to get views and that is some
very important information when you're
planning out a batch of videos so check
that out in the show notes but let's get
into step two the second step is to
create an outline or script out the
content so once you've defined the topic
the title and the thumbnail then I like
to figure out okay what's the structure
is there points and I don't script my
videos word for word but I definitely
create an outline you'll notice that
some people when they watch the video
version of the podcast they say why are
you looking down and I I say well one
it's because I've got notes and two
what's a video podcast and so I
understand that it's not a super two
camera delivered video like a
traditional YouTube video but I'm okay
with that because of the nature of the
content what am I looking at what am I
reading from I'm reading from an outline
I'm reading from the organization and
when you think about planning your
content ahead today I'm doing a bunch of
talking head videos me direct to camera
direct to audio but there's also a
couple different types of content that
you could batch produce for example you
could do multiple interviews I love the
story of Jamie tardy the eventual
millionaire she got clear on her content
strategy and started a video podcast
interviewing millionaires virtually and
so she figured out her content strategy
it was a video podcast an interview show
and not only that because of honoring
family and other things in her business
and other responsibilities she said I'm
only going to schedule these interviews
in Monday I'm going to schedule them
back to back to back to back clustering
that energy clustering that effort
what's cool about this is it doesn't
matter where you are in the world using
simple software you can have a guest
jump on interview them and then turn
that into a YouTube video and an audio
podcast and have a sustainable content
format that builds your brand that's why
we wanted to bring today's episode to
you by streamwiththink.com because if
this was the content format you wanted
to lean into then I highly recommend
using stream yard stream yard is the
tool we use for doing interviews live
streams but one of my favorite features
is their perfect record feature so for
the think media podcast when I interview
a guest virtually they jump on stream
yard and it's being captured to the
guest hard drive as well as my my hard
drive and it uploads a high quality
version all to the cloud so that you can
either just export it as it is or you
have each angle isolated in 1080P high
resolution with great audio that's
uploaded separately so that a
professional edit of that interview can
be done afterwards so if you want to
keep it super simple stream yard is
perfect or if you want to go a little
bit more advanced a little extra crispy
as we say here at think media it is an
incredible tool it does a lot more than
what I'm even talking about but for
video podcasting it is a must and so you
can go to streamwiththink.com or check
out the link in the show notes to grab a
free trial of stream yard and get
started with your batch production
interviews right away and so we're
talking about different kinds of content
that you could batch produce you could
batch produce a bunch of interviews in a
row you could batch produce a bunch of
talking head videos in a row you could
also batch produce multiple YouTube
shorts perhaps you've seen across social
media on Instagram reels or Tick Tock or
YouTube shorts what has kind of been
known as the Alex hermosi Style videos
where he's talking straight to camera
there's captions on screen and they're
not just a clip taken from a
conversation somewhere else they're
actually structured content that he's
delivering there's a hook to it there's
content in the middle and I've done a
shoot like that two times now with about
20 to 25 shorts all in one batch again I
prepare ahead of time I get an idea of
what the hook is maybe if it's gonna
loop I kind of script the beginning and
the end so that it can loop on social
media but whether you really dial in all
the details or just plan out some good
topics it's a powerful way to create
multiple videos in one sitting and when
it comes to Vertical video video perhaps
you want to upload those more regularly
than once a week and so if you shoot
something like 20 or 25 which take a
breath I know that might sound
intimidating but just like anything else
it's kind of like a muscle that you grow
up into it's like an endurance that you
grow into where that definitely sounds
overwhelming at the start but it could
become pretty practical when you get
into the Rhythm and the habit and the
discipline of content creation and then
the final step when it comes to batch
producing content and creating more
videos in one day is filming the videos
now that's actually going to be part
four in this series so make sure you're
subscribed but let's talk about another
big idea for how you could get more
content done in less time okay so our
second big idea is to create more
shorter videos essentially if you were
going to prepare some content that was
going to turn into a 12 or 18 minute or
25 minute video what would happen if you
turn that into multiple videos one of
the truths about YouTube is that if you
double your uploads you can double your
views I know that it's not not always
guaranteed but let's say you're used to
getting 100 views per video If you
upload two videos then you're probably
gonna get 200 views and oftentimes it
becomes exponential because if you can
increase the amount of videos you're
uploading to YouTube want to get 100 one
will get 80 but then one will get
2235 and you're getting more chances to
have a breakout video a vfm video vfm
means viral for me one video that gets
above and beyond which you typically get
for views this actually reminds me of a
story of when I went to the Mukilteo
ferry with my Mom we are on a date day
and we are going to go to the islands in
Washington state and as we were waiting
for the ferry to arrive we grabbed a cup
of coffee and we were walking along the
deck enjoying the sunrise looking at the
beautiful views when we noticed a
fisherman that was there fishing in the
Puget Sound but what was unique about
this fisherman is he didn't just have
one fishing people he actually had eight
fishing poles set up along the railing
on the dock now why would he do this
well he had more opportunities to catch
fish he had more Hooks In The Water
multiple fishing poles and he was just
sitting there in a beach chair
monitoring these different poles to see
if one of them was to get a bite
ultimately increasing his chances of
getting a catch I love this story
because it illustrates the principle on
YouTube of more uploads give you more
opportunities for views subscribers and
growth and so the million dollar
question is how can I create more
uploads in less time and our second big
idea is let's create more shorter videos
and so one example is ask this question
could I make three quality shorts
instead of one longer video perhaps
you're going to deliver a video that has
three big points it's gonna take you
around seven minutes after the edit it
well could that information be delivered
in YouTube shorts instead a little bit
more polish a little bit more energy but
now you have stretched the one upload
into three and when it comes to staying
consistent on YouTube maybe you look
ahead and you think I want to go on
vacation or I want to take a month off
and certainly you could just stop
uploading but when you multiply your
uploads this also gives you the
opportunity to schedule a few uploads so
while you're gone videos are still
coming out so if you had four points in
one video those could become a YouTube
short instead of here are four tips for
saving money on your taxes you could say
here is one tip you need to know about
saving money on your taxes four
different videos one tip each four
different uploads this is one of our
favorite strategies that we talk about
in our video ranking Academy community
and I actually asked some of our VRA
students how are they using the series
strategy gender for richer shares tips
for business owners on how to Outsource
your marketing and this is what she said
said next week I'm releasing my first
series one video each week for seven
weeks each video is an overview of a
chapter in my book the first video is
the overview the second video is chapter
one Etc the book is about Outsourcing
and delegation this is an amazing tip
from Jen because not only is she
creating a series but she's also
leveraging content that she's already
developed elsewhere in book format to
create videos from it so she doesn't
have to reinvent the wheel as much this
is the type of thinking that will get
your time back so that you have more
sanity more time with your family more
time working on your next project Lewis
said I have 10 shorts as a series and
I'm planning to upload one per day so of
course you could do random shorts that
have nothing to do with each other or
you actually could deliver shorts in a
series and certain viewers could be
peaked in their interest to go check out
your library and see the other videos in
the series but you may be wondering Sean
how can I do this if I'm not teaching
direct to camera or interviewing and
doing education and I love this example
from Marco he said I'm currently working
on a series where I visit towns in a
single province in Italy and present
local food and tour homes for sale it's
easy to group them all in a series since
I batch shoot them all in a week the
next series will be in a different
region and Province so what we've
discovered is that travel channels can
do this as well or even vlogging
channels instead of perhaps releasing a
vlog of an entire day you could actually
break the day into Parts if something
interesting is happening in the
beginning of the day in the middle and
in the end instead of one 20 minute Vlog
it could be three five minute vlogs
instead of one video trying to cram your
entire experience at a theme park you
could cover specific aspects of the
theme park work spend one day filming at
Disney World and turn it into three or
six or ten different videos so the two
big ideas to help you get more done in
less time are tapping into the power of
batch producing your videos and creating
more short videos subscribe for part two
because I'm gonna be revealing our think
media strategies for multiplying your
content even more using AI tools and
smart content repurposing and check out
stream with think.com there's a link in
the show notes and this will give you a
free trial on our favorite software for
live streaming across multiple platforms
but also for batch producing podcasts
many times from my home office I will
use stream yards perfect record feature
to record YouTube videos and video
podcasts it's so easy to use it's all
web-based it's packed with lots of very
cool tools and for the serious content
creator that wants to start getting more
views and more growth and have better
tools behind you I highly recommend
checking out stream with think.com and
if you found this content valuable rate
review and like wherever you watch or
listen I appreciate you so much and I
can't wait to connect with you on the
next episode